très bien très bien alors qu'est-ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui j'ai travaillé j'ai
travaillé tu travailles toi ça m'arrive
régulièrement
j'ai fait une heure de cardio
merci Clarisse merci
pas possible
[Applaudissements]
j'adore cette arme
je propose qu'on refasse un ni oui ni
pont avec Gilles Verdez
[Applaudissements]
doucement
on s'avance comme ça comme tu es grand
on fait attention ambiance toi bien sur
le bout là voilà et là doucement comme
ça
[Musique]
non non
non
on va le faire juste se faire ni oui ni
pont avec les autres aussi Jean-Michel
on partage
très fort Jean-Pierre Descombes je lui
ai demandé de revenir en faire un tien
et voilà je lui fais un gros bisou je
vois qu'il vienne avant la fondation on
va le faire venir pour faire un petit ni
oui ni non et c'est un mec que j'adore
et je sais que voilà il a des petits
soucis de santé je fais un gros bisou à
mon Jean-Pierre on est là on n'oublie
pas comment ça va toi tout va bien ça va
tu es où toi maintenant je comprends
plus ton Sud dans le sud toujours
toujours heureux heureux seul mais
heureux seul mais heureux on peut être
seul et heureux avec mes moutons voilà
tu as combien de moutons plus de 4000
tu leur as donné des mots
encore
une bergerie et une bergère qui a des
moutons tu habites avec Michel pas ton
corps
je reviens quand je reviens quand vous
m'appelez le Mercredi Jeudi camion le
Mercredi Jeudi ça va ça me va
parfaitement
mercredi jeudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ouais
pas
à champion
[Rires]
comment ça va toi impeccable
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal et plus lourds c'est pas
mal allez plus loin
j'ai pris des cours
[Musique]
est-ce que tu vois maintenant je vois
pas alors
[Applaudissements]
pas besoin de toi vas-y non mais
je suis myope et à peu près ce [__]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me concentre à mort c'est un rideau
pour faire de la violence sans dire un
rideau de
matin maintenant puisque tu te réveilles
plus le matin oui je dors tu dors
maintenant je suis à quelle heure
jusqu'à 8h 8h30 c'est tout
tes enfants ils ont quel âge mes enfants
22 bientôt 17 et 13 ah mais tu te
réveilles quand même avec eux le matin
ils sont tes habits tout chez toi ils
habitent tous chez moi alors c'est pas
la peine de répéter tout ce que vous
voulez
non mais je te le dis non mais c'est
vrai pourquoi tu répètes tout ce que je
dis pour pas perdre ta peur de perdre un
petit peu pourquoi
j'ai fait des combats
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas d'eau
c'est gentil
Cyril Cyril et dwin demain vous allez
partir directement des quarts de finale
comme on a eu un désistement vous êtes
peut-être de série 2 on va faire format
de 7 de si je prends décisif voilà
jusqu'au bout du tournoi votre match est
prévu à 12h est-ce que c'est bon pour
vous deux j'ai un très gros match demain
midi
[Applaudissements]
professionnel
[Musique]
toute la journée est-ce que tu as un
chien
j'avais un chien mais il est où
maintenant il est parti loin tu sais mon
chien je vais aller sur les rivières
[Rires]
je vais te dire pourquoi personne ne
veut de moi
ah oui alors
[Applaudissements]
attends